[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vous pas une solution qui
est intéressante si vous avez des
problèmes de wifi de répartition de wifi
j'ai un truc qui est intéressant c'est
une vidéo qui réalise en partenariat
avec des vélos et d'évoquer une solution
qui est pas mal qui est même plutôt
assez intéressante sessad et volent au
magic de wifi multi rootkit vous expose
le problème jeunes explique le truc ici
vous avez votre box internet
ça c'est votre appartement ça alors que
j'ai trouvé sur internet ici vous avez
séjour cuisine salle d'eau chambre eu
une chambre deux chambres trois salles
de bains vous avez des murs qui sont
assez épais et qui laisse malpasset
signal votre box elle est parfaite dans
séjour cuisine salle de bain vous êtes
bien chambrer une chambre aux 300 peut
voir ça leur chambre deux là vous avez
absolument pas de réseau quand vous êtes
dans ce cas de figure la ca c'est la
galère en gros vous avez un seul endroit
d'où aimez votre signal wifi et pour
toutes les personnes qui vont être à
l'extérieur cette zone c'est pas ça le
wifi passe pas au cap thomas et les
débiteurs franchement très mauvais ça
vous connaissez c'est ce qu'on appelle
le wi-fi le wifi c'est bien il a ses
points positifs et ces points négatifs
et pour pallier à ces problèmes on a ce
qu'on appelle le wifi mesh
à la différence du russie un peu
standard avec le wifi mesh vous allez
maîtres de plusieurs endroits vous
allait émettre d'ici vous allez par
exemple émettre d'ici vous allez par
exemple émettre d'ici et pourquoi pas
émettre d'ici ça vous permet donc de
couvrir plusieurs zones cette zone là va
être complètement couvertes par cette
partie là toute cette zone là il va être
couverte par cette partie ici cette zone
là va être couverte par cette partie là
et cette zone là va être couverts par
cette partie là à la différence du wifi
un peu standard où vous n'aviez qu'une
partie de votre appartement qu'ils
étaient couverts vous laissant des zones
d'ombré dans cette partie là là vous
avez l'intégralité de votre appartement
qui est ouvert vous avez un wifi de
partout avec le mels ingall et surtout
avec le nen ssid cette idée je sais pas
si c'est un terme qui vous parle trop
mais c'est le nom de votre réseau wifi
imaginons votre réseau wifi s'appelle
maison eh bien vous avez sûr
box actuelle un seul réseau wifi maison
qui va dans toute votre maison est là à
la différence vous allez avoir quatre
points d'émission wifi 3 ou 4 points
d'émission wifi ça c'est à vous de voir
et s'appelleront tous maison donc quand
vous allez vous déplacer dans votre
maison vous allez vous connectés au même
réseau maison c'est ça qui est vraiment
intéressant avec le wifi mesh vous allez
ici à voir votre réseau maison qui va
émettre
ici vous allez avoir également votre
réseau qui s'appelle maison qui va
émettre ici mais également ici est
également ici en gros partout vous allez
être chez vous vous allez avoir votre
réseau maison qui va émettre de partout
vous allez vous balader dans vos
différentes pièces et vous allez
toujours être cotée sur le réseau maison
en fonction de groves lettre vous allez
changer dans votre quête vous devez vous
connecter
donc soit toujours connecté sur le même
réseau s'appelle maison ça c'est génial
c'est le wifi mais chez moi j'ai de
rencontrer une autre problématique dans
un ancien appartement dans lequel
j'étais à savoir que ma boxe était posée
à un endroit et mon décodeur avec ma
télé était posé un autre endroit du coup
c'était un peu la galère je n'avais pas
me tirer un câble ethernet énorme dans
tout mon appartement j'ai fait appel à
des cp ça marchait bien
en gros avec cette solution là là que je
vous présentais plus en détail des vole
au magic de où il fit multi rôle titre
vous allez pouvoir connecter
l'intégralité de votre maison vous allez
pouvoir pallier aux problématiques des
spasmes or les endroits où internet ne
passe pas vous allez pouvoir déporter
votre décodeur par rapport à votre box
vous à pouvoir faire pas mal de choses à
voir une collection femme enfin ça c'est
cool
première chose on regarde ce qu'à
l'intérieur
[Musique]
on a donc 3 cpl celui ci je pense que
c'est celui que je branche ma boxe il ya
une seule prise ethernet de la boxe ici
pour récupérer internet et on suit venir
passer internet dans mon courant
électrique parce que c'est comme ça que
marche le système cpl internet arrivent
directement la rentrer là dedans est
envoyé directement dans votre réseau
électrique est ensuite récupérée par ce
petit boîtier qui va lui soit pouvant
diffuser en wifi dans une zone
géographique limitée autour de lui
soient directement ici en ethernet vous
pouvez soit branché votre décodeur soit
gros ordinateur ce que vous voulez en
gros avec ce kit multiroom vous avez
accès à deux endroits ça c'est le câble
pour brancher de ma box directement
annoncé pl le temps de jeter un coup
d'oeil à la documentation et on va
s'installer ça et je vous dit ce que
j'en pense
la première chose à faire c'est branché
vos prises dès vau-l'eau avant toute
chose une il faut attendre qu'elle passe
ici au blanc et de quand les deux sont
blanches
on peut continuer ensuite je branche mon
adaptateur des volo à une prise de
courant je branche avec son câble
directement à ma place ensuite vous avez
un processus de cryptage qui s'est
pendant 3 minutes maximum une fois c'est
fini tout est stabilisé et il n'y a plus
rien qui dit être blanc donc là c'est
bon tout est ok ensuite c'est hyper
simple une fois que vous avez tout
paramétrer que vous avez paramétrer
votre application mais vous avez votre
réseau wifi qui est là vous avez
internet vous avez votre cpu principal
qui est relié directement à votre box et
ensuite vous avez les deux satellites
qui sont là c'est très facile à
configurer
je suis connecté sur mon wifi
directement avec mon ses pelles à côté
sa large et bien c'est rapide c'est
pratique c'est plutôt cool
c'est vrai que son expérience ça
fonctionne plutôt bien c'est ce qui est
vraiment bien ce qui est très pratique
c'est quel que soit l'endroit où vous
allez être vous allez avoir la même
point très positif quelque chose qui se
connectent très rapidement très
facilement vous êtes guidé au travers de
l'application vous prenez pas la tête
donc il n'y a pas besoin de
connaissances particulières book pour
toutes les personnes qui se disent ouais
je veux bien mais ça a l'air un peu
compliqué rassurez vous vous êtes
vraiment pris en main vous avez votre
application qui vous sert elle est
configuré très facilement plus qui coule
c'est que pour connecter vous avez qu à
venir ce cas les codes-barres donc ça va
reconnaître directement vos appareils
vous embêtez pas c'est vraiment hyper
hyper simple ça veut donc vous
solutionner pas mal de problèmes et que
vous regardez des vidéos sans d'être
flic sur youtube pourquoi pas la chaîne
de monsieur heureux que vous soyez un
gamer pas forcément hardcore gamers et
vous ayez des jeux auxquels vous aimez
bien jouer de temps en temps ça a un
sens si vous faites de la réalité
virtuelle ça ira parfaitement bien pour
du streaming musique spotify deezer
pourquoi pas en roaming ça marche
parfaitement bien sûr permettra de
couvrir des zones que vous ne pouviez
pas forcément couvrir donc ça c'est
aussi hyper intéressant si vous avez une
smart tv aussi ça fonctionnera et
évidemment pour surfer sur internet
en gros pour résumer la des veaux magic
2 ça se configure très facilement c'est
rapide ça marche bien ça vous solutionne
tous vos problèmes de configuration et
de zone dans laquelle vous n'aviez pas
internet je trouve ça franchement hyper
intéressant je sais pas ce que vous
utilisez déjà une solution cpl est ce
que vous utilisez du wifi mesh
est ce qu'une solution comme celle là
dévolue au magic de wifi ça pourrait
vous tentez en tout cas si ça vous
battre vous ai mis un lien en bas dans
la description vous pouvez y aller moi
comme ça c'est intéressant je vous
invite à marquer toutes vos questions
interrogations suggestions tout ce que
vous avez en votre commentaire je donne
rendez vous dès demain pour continuer à
parler tech nous embrassades machaho